hello good afternoon this is sky knees
at 1:00 our main story here today the
battle to be Britain's next prime
minister will see the final two
candidates for Tory leader decided today
contender and brexit campaigner Andrea
led 'some told Sky News his political
editor that she thinks the pound hasn't
suffered since the vote to leave the EU
and she spoke about the accusations that
she has an offshore mortgage and that
she's lied on her CV for me the
important thing is we can make a huge
success of leaving the EU giving
ourselves more prospects for growth and
opportunity and so on and I think we
should be looking at that if you're
Prime Minister though people want to
know that you have a fix on what's
actually happening rather than what you
want to happen
take sterling you just said that it was
wasn't correct that it was a disaster
but it's fallen - against the dollar its
lowest level since 1985 what would you
turn that fall so I mean sterling is an
incredibly resilient currency and it has
dropped a bit of in the region of 10
percent but you know the fact is if you
look at for example the drop after the
2008 financial crisis it was far bigger
far far bigger
so yes sterling has dropped a bits been
some concern about your job record about
your CV have you actually managed large
groups of people in your banking career
yes I have yes yes and are you confident
that your you have given a fair account
of what you've done in your bag
absolutely yes your CV is correct yes
and why are you only a candidate not
publishing your tax return I mean that
that's I've been very clear I will
publish my tax returns if I'm in the
final two and they're very boring by the
way but the point is that I want to
defend my colleagues from the constant
pressure to hand out every detail of
their private life between your CV and
your tax returns it would show that you
had some offshore investments in biotech
companies those two things or buy-to-let
company involved in offshore nothing
like that I mean literally if you buy a
book from Amazon and they book it in
Luxembourg and it shows on your bank
statement
is that you know what does that say
about you you know in this instance we
were shopping around for a cheap
mortgage and the mortgage was offered by
a bank who booked it in the Channel
Islands now that there's no advantage to
me it was just a good deal